a recent study revealed a shocking
statistic about the world's wealthiest
people how exactly did they make all
their money it wasn't gambling it wasn't
day trading it wasn't even building
businesses in fact the way that these
people got rich took a really really
long time and tons of discipline ninety
percent of the world's wealthiest people
made their money in real estate some
people did it by investing in real
estate and others simply by buying their
personal home over long periods of time
real estate prices go up and
Millionaires and billionaires keep
getting richer sometimes the simplest
thing is the most effective